does the film industry make people crazy
and if not why that perception
yeah i think there's a a lot of crazy
that comes hand in hand with being an
artist anyway there's an eccentricity
with um
creative beings we're dreamers i think
any time you
you live your life based on
kind of playing the odds of the lottery
how does it not make you crazy as
i talk about in my book um what other
business do you know of really you know
music
film dance art where you could literally
be homeless living on a friend's couch
and get an audition
for that one role and become
the next gal gadot you could become the
next you know
jason bateman can be anybody and you
know you think about doctors lawyers
successful business people they they
have a path
they still may be trying to figure out
that path but they usually go to college
they'll often figure out a plan and a
road
get get their eye on a prize and work
their way to it you know
medical school being six years and then
residency that's that's a game plan
for artists for what we do the game plan
is bust your ass
you know make it you know fake it till
you make it you know it's it's
never give up it's i can't quit because
my break may come tomorrow
and i think a lot of people uh
coming up that way and trying to find
their path uh in their place
it can make you crazy i've found trying
to find my path has made me a little
nuts sometimes as i say a little south
of sanity
um i also find once we get in a position
of authority
it's i think no other industry is as
is unkind as ours
and i know everybody says there's
horrible people in every industry i've
been around every industry
you can imagine because of what i do and
the things that i've experienced
in shot and i it's
mind-boggling how people are treated and
yeah the i think the me too movement
and then the aftermath of that and
people and how we talk to one another
was so long overdue
but it's it's amazing what people get
away with and i still think they get
away with it
you know how they talk to each other and
treat people i
and i that that can make people crazy
you know i think it does
sure what about people's reactions to
artists
you know there's all these sort of
stigmas that artists are selfish or
whatever
can we talk about other people's
reactions can i swear
uh okay one swear word one f
okay i i have a brother who i i love
more than anything he's very successful
and he has a motto that he's always kind
of looked at what with what we do and
he's always said look you want to be an
artist go paint in a park on
saturday
get a job life's a business don't
don't you know life's life goes by fast
you don't want to look back when you're
40 or 50 and wonder what happened
you know he's the smart squirrel that
always stashed away during the winter
you know for the winter months and i i
see that i
i came from a my mother was from
manhattan
from new york a very successful lawyer
was her father she was very successful
real estate agent
her brother is a you know was the
director of primary care for kaiser
and the fact that i didn't go to college
the fact that i just wanted to be a
dreamer
uh figure out what i'm gonna do with
myself and you know the three choices i
picked were
were music dirt bikes and films so you
don't need a college education for
either and all of them are pretty
pretty big shots in the dark i think
people look at artists
and as i call us
[Music]
you know people who who express
themselves for a living
a lot of people don't understand it i i
find when i talk with different schools
different institutions a lot of parents
um are more supportive now than they
were when i was growing up because
you have things like you know somebody
like mark zuckerberg coming along and
creating facebook you have somebody who
created twitter or pinterest and
all these things that one day they they
wrote a code for something
that made him a billionaire overnight so
i think we have a little
more leeway and a little more grace from
people who look down at the dreamers and
the the creative beings
but i still i still get sad when i talk
to a lot of the
the youngsters coming up and it's like
they don't have the support from their
family especially
the ones that are going to community
college because they don't have the
financial means
to put themselves to a good school and
they certainly don't have the support of
parents i actually encounter some very
well to do people in the community
colleges whose parents are like i'll
write the check to go to usc tomorrow
you want to go to yale we'll make it
happen but you're going to go down this
path
you're on your own and i think that's
unfortunate
so i think there's a little bit of a
stigma still
but i don't think it's as bad as it was
when when i was coming up
do you think people in community
colleges i know we're going off on a
little bit of a tangent but
are less competitive with one another i
mean i went to a community college
at that time the internet was just
starting up so you couldn't look
somebody up and say oh
what's this person's deal so you could
be more anonymous but i feel like it
wasn't like
uber competitive and i was able to enjoy
myself there
i've gotten to the point where whenever
a community college says
would you could you can you the answer
is yes
because there's a purity there is a
drive there is a determination without
prejudice
i find a lot of the people at community
colleges now are on their second their
second wave of life
they're often parents they take buses
and
public modes of transportation to get to
school they're putting themselves
through you know paying a few hundred
dollars a unit to try to get
to something and i enjoy
that crowd a lot i do work with a lot of
universities and i
appreciate and cherish that time too but
the mindset
is different i can tell you without
naming names there are
universities that accept the fact that
their students will not
finish their thesis film after having
three years to do it and they still
get a beautiful diploma and march down
march down the uh the stage and
i don't understand that our business
will not
hire you if you don't finish a task if
you don't
show up and you don't deliver you don't
work so i don't know why you'd reward
them and and i had a chair at a very
prominent
film school university tell me once we
don't want to deal with the lawsuits
so we pass them and if i'm breaking
protocol by coming out and saying that i
don't care
that's how it is and that doesn't happen
at community college
you have guys like dan watanabe and
chris rossiter
and some wonderful teachers who have
been that and done there and spent more
time on a set than most university
professors have
and they are very happy to fail you
uh if you don't do the work and i
appreciate that because that's how it is
remember alex p keaton from family ties
he was always throwing community
colleges under the bus that was his like
go-to thing but i i think they are
salted the earth and i i it's funny i
will
tell you when they first when i first
wrote my book
and a few of the universities were
getting excited and a few blacklisted me
and
um just by the title of the book because
i used to be welcome to give lectures
and workshops and speak and then as soon
as they read the manuscript that was oh
well the title of your book you're out
and it's like i have no problem with
film school
if you didn't grow up around it you need
to learn these things all i want to do
is teach you what they don't teach you
there's the business of the business of
distribution and how to get financing
you know
not french new year or what angle to put
the camera and the lights at there's so
much more to learn
doing your own deals production deals
distribution agreements
actor agreements how to approach talent
how to approach money you don't talk
about that in film school that's what i
that's what i teach and when i first
got people excited about the book and it
started like well you know there's
there's nine community colleges out
where you are and we'd really love to
get you roped in with them i at first
was a little kind of like
what am i getting into here and i went
and spoke
for my first time at a community college
and i never looked back i
loved the passion these people had and
they're not kids
we have people our age there i mean
there's i go to some of these workshops
there's people in their 60s and 70s
trying to figure out
their next chapter and i love that
they've been that done there they're old
souls they've lived
they've scrapped for everything they've
got they fought for every piece of real
estate they own
usually and i i just think that makes
for
better artists i think it makes for
better human beings
you